in the native Java datastore API all
property values are indexed by default
if you forget to think carefully about
which properties really need to be
indexed you can end up with index bloat
however objectify helps you out and by
default property values are not indexed
when you use objectify so if you want a
property to be indexed you need to add
the at index annotation to the property
however if you prefer that by default
all the properties of a class are
indexed then you add the at index
annotation to the class and then you can
add at an index to each property that
you don't want to be indexed you can
also add condition so that our
properties only index if it meets
certain criteria for example only
indexes property if the value is greater
than 100 there's good documentation
about conditional indexing in the
objectify developers guide so what I'm
going to want you to do next is actually
go read the developer's guide it's at
this link or actually an easier way to
find it it's just a search on Google for
objectify this brings you down into the
open source project robbed objectify
then you click on the wiki and then
expand the users guide and you go to the
queries and indexes page